hello everybody so my name is billy
pramf i'm from paterson new jersey i've
lived in paterson for over 30 years of
my life
um i'm united states air force veteran
first generation american
parents they migrated to this country
from ghana west africa
and um you know they came here to give
me a a better life give me a better
get a better standard of living they
didn't really have much of a
positive life back home in ghana and you
know when i came to this country or when
i was when i was raised in this country
when my parents came here they they
wanted to do something different
there weren't a lot of opportunities
growing up my mother and her relatives
they
lost everything that they had shortly
after her father passed away
and they were all living in a kitchen
probably twice the size of this little
area here right there wow they cleared
out the kitchen put a bunch of bunk beds
in there
it was about 13 people living inside of
that uh inside of that that room
and my mother she sold everything that
she had you know
she sold everything that she owned and
she decided to move to the united
kingdom
if you don't know ghana was colonized by
the english so it was quite simple to
become a citizen
wow um in england she wanted to bring
her older brother her older brother
punked out he just what's that for some
reason didn't want to go over
and that's okay um so she went over
there and just did some of the
worst jobs in the world um to try and
make ends meet
and um eventually she ended up meeting
my father they came to the united states
and um i popped out yeah along with
my older brother and little sister and
the rest is history man wow man
american dream uh i would say so i would
say so i would join the air force
joined the air force awesome you know um
and even with that joining the united
states air force i i decided to do it
because
um at the time i was a big time barack
obama supporter you know
big time big-time bronco obama supporter
um i thought he was gonna do a lot of
great things for this country you know
my parents
coming here and seeing you know i never
thought we'd ever see an
african-american president
ever and here he is he's on television
and out that was at a moment when i was
feeling ultra gung-ho american so you
know this is a great thing
and you know i i wanted to do something
bigger than myself i felt you know
what's the best thing that i could do
um to give back to my country at this
point my father had passed away
um mother was having a very difficult
time making ends meet and i said you
know
i can go to the air force because i'm
not really getting much of an education
here in community college so i dropped
out of there decided
to sign up for the uh the air force
initially wanted to be a marine by the
way
but you know they didn't want to take me
they said my score is too high they
didn't
oh yeah which i thought was which i
thought was ridiculous because i'm like
you know i want to be infantry he's like
why do you want to be infantry you can
do something else like why don't you do
like uh
like admin or something i don't want to
be an admin so anyway
and then i'm joined in the united states
air force i was stationed at raf milton
hall and i worked as an aerospace ground
equipment mechanic um
for about two years um i didn't end up
finishing my full term while i was in
the air force and the reason being is
because of uh
how things went when barack obama
decided to get involved with uh with
libya
so at that time our base rf milton hall
were a support base
uh we did enter refueling for our sister
base sorry if lake and heath they had
all the fighter jets they were
you know going out doing a combat thing
we had to go and take care of them
one day or at least the day when this
whole thing kicked off
nobody had any idea we were about to go
into libya until we were already in
libya wow
in fact that day i was at the club on
base with one of my sergeants who were
hanging out
had a couple of drinks i go home no big
deal alarms start going off on the base
jets start going crazy they're flying
off and it was at that point that
at that point that it became apparent
that this isn't just a job you know
because it felt like a job the entire
time you know you wear a suit go to work
do your job
you know go back hang out with your
friends and and rally all night you know
and um at that point it became apparent
that you know something serious is
happening and at that point
i thought that you know it's probably
the russians or the chinese or something
i'm like who's who's going to steamroll
england you know for us to
what's england doing it's not happening
you know and um
we ended up having to go to the squadron
building they come out they tell us hey
we're doing uh 24-hour shifts well
16-hour shifts seven days a week
until mission accomplishes orders by the
potus wow we're
instilling a humanitarian no-fly zone
over libya that's uh
how they try to try to sugarcoat it make
it sound not so bad
and me like a [ __ ] i actually got in
trouble for this me like a [ __ ] decided
to
raise my drunken hand and say i don't
understand why are we going because
listen whenever whatever commander an
officer
that says something you know or do
something not just you do it it's like
they say oh
any questions it's a trick question you
don't answer the question you know you
know
and and you know like an idiot raise my
hand i'm like well why are we doing this
doesn't make any sense you know libya is
not a threat to the constitution the
people or
anything like that why are we in england
getting involved and putting american
lives at risk and he kind of just comes
and said listen
you do that you get an article 15 and
that's it all right
article 15 is like it's like what are
the worst punishments you can get you
can lose rank and get arrested
all kinds of stuff can happen to you it
really depends on the severity of what
happens um
and from that point on you know there
were a lot of uh special forces planes
that started coming to our base at the
time the cv-22 osprey was uh
not many people knew about the plane i
don't know if you know what it looks
like but uh anyway is that the thing
with the like the jets go up and down
right right right yeah i played fallout
so they had that exactly exactly so
so um that was the first time i saw one
of those planes and they weren't from
our base we're from somewhere else these
were all special forces planes that were
special forces units that were gonna be
using these planes and um
the entire time i just couldn't help but
but think to myself that man like
uh people are gonna die tonight you know
and at this point you know i was i was
very politically involved but
i would say i was still in a daze or
like in a haze as to like what's really
really going on in the world here
and when i saw this i decided you know
if i go out and i give this generator to
these guys and they go out and do what
they have to do people are gonna die
people are gonna get hurt
and um i didn't really want any parts of
that i disobeyed those orders
ended up getting in trouble yeah i got
in trouble for that but you know looking
back at it i don't feel like i did the
wrong thing
you know at the time barack obama made
this claim we're going to go into libya
and do this stuff but he did it when
um he did it when uh congress was uh
when they couldn't come to a conclusion
for the debt ceiling they wanted to
raise it in 2000
it was the shutdown or whatever correct
so it was shut down people in the
military didn't know if they were going
to get paid and all kinds of stuff and
something in the back of my mind and i'm
glad and i was right you know in the
back of my mind i felt like this doesn't
feel right you know
even with iraq you know a lot of people
didn't agree with iraq but at least
george bush got a declaration of war to
go and do what he did right
the aumf right so i saw that and i'm
like you know
this this isn't adding up to me you know
they're on the base they're telling us
that you know
oh don't pay attention i need to fake
news it's on television you can only
really get cnn and afn armed forces
network on on base and
the only thing it was really saying was
the humanitarian no-fly zone has been
successful it's like no real no real uh
answers as to what happened but when i
went off base i went to my girlfriend at
the time's house and i started looking
at al jazeera press 24 and all these
other news stations
the protests that were happening in
libya were saying the completely
different thing than what they were
saying in the united states in the
united states are saying
oh we're doing a humanitarian thing and
they're supporting us because they want
to get rid of gaddafi when in reality
they're like
we don't need nato interference you know
it's like we've got our own revolution
going on this is during the arab spring
we've got our own revolution going on we
don't want any american interference
lo and behold this happens benghazi
happened shortly after that
you start bombing lands you start
bombing farmlands and all kinds of stuff
doing things that in my opinion
completely violated the geneva
convention so when i saw this i was like
this is treason
you know we didn't get we didn't get any
authorization from congress to do this
and
now we're out here killing innocent
people like i signed up to defend my
country and i go out and
wage these nonsensical wars and you see
what history
is as uh has laid out shortly after that
happened you know
all these uh all these terrorist cells
that came together took over tripoli
they created isis started funneling oil
through syria and um
the rest is history and now in africa
which and i tell this to a lot of people
a lot of people aren't aware of is
you know the reason why i don't support
barack obama anymore is we have the
first black president
and he has done more for slavery than
anybody else in history
because right now in in libya wow it
should i'm pretty sure it's still going
on right now in libya they have these
open-air slave markets where they're
going around collecting people
from my parents country ghana they're
arrested they're kidnapping people all
across
the country and selling them off into
slavery and that would have never
happened
whether you like gaddafi or not it would
have never happened if you were still
alive
and um when i when i saw those kinds of
things i kind of just wanted to get out
i wanted to go back home
and uh it was a different story when i
came home as well because going to
england
i got culture shock going over there you
know i saw how
everything was very different there's
cameras all over the place i'm pretty
sure you've been to england before all
right yeah they got
the crazy surveillance everywhere right
everywhere have you ever seen that meme
where it's like george orwell's old
house yeah there's a camera next to it
yeah
that's exactly what it is yeah you know
they had cameras all over the entire
place and um
i i just was like you know i understand
why we shot these guys and started our
own country man
no offense to the english over there all
right i've got english kids but it's
like you know
i i i saw this and i just i just was not
vibing with the country i just wanted to
go back to america
and coming back to america the country
was totally different
um before i left there was a lot of
optimism everybody was happy first black
president things are going good you know
it's all great but then occupy wall
street happened everybody's out here
protesting we didn't know what we're
gonna do with the bailouts and
everyone's for socialism everyone's for
communism everybody's on this whole
marxist train right now and it just it
just blew my mind it didn't make much
sense to me
because the only thing that kept
repeating in my mind is i had a seventh
grade teacher
in um school 18 and patterson's name was
mr damacolo
growing up he grew up in uh in fascist
italy during the times of
world war ii and it would tell us these
kinds of things about you know be very
mindful and be very
be very careful about these leaders that
come in and promise all these kinds of
things and they start
drifting the country into socialism it
always sounds like a good idea on paper
but in practice it never
never ends well i remember a lot of kids
were just like haha that'll never happen
america
you know nobody really believed that and
look where we are today
you promise free stuff to people they're
gonna take it oh yeah of course and um
and and look at where we are right now i
got sick and tired of seeing this kind
of stuff
i got i really really got sick and tired
of seeing this and um i kind of just
kept the back seat and kept a lot of my
opinions to myself at this time
i was very very big into ron paul yeah
dude oh man
massively ron paul and the funniest
thing is before i went into the air
force
uh this was around 2000 late 2008 early
2009
my friend dan avery and rich eason uh
they
sat me down in front of a starbucks in
the glen rock and we're talking about
politics i'm like oh yeah barack obama
and
these guys are all ron paul dudes do you
know about the fractional reserve
banking system
[Laughter]
do you know about austrian economics
yeah you know the
the fed rabbit hole right and i'm like
what are you talking about it's like do
you know how money's created
you know how's obama going to pay for
these kinds of things and i had no idea
and then you know back then it's like
flip phones were still kind of the thing
pulls out a flip phone and uh not a flip
phone the uh the chocolate verizon
chocolate phony pulls it out
we go on youtube and we start looking at
uh ron paul videos right now
i don't want to watch this old guy this
is just kind of and this was like before
the republican guy dude yeah you know
what i mean at that point i'm like
republican dude
now you're a republican all day all day
bro wait
real quick we mentioned you're running
in uh new jersey's nice district i'm
running in the knife district as a
republican yeah yeah all right all right
continue continuing it's a great intro
by the way
so we're going keep going so um you know
we're watching this video about ron paul
and i'm like i don't want to watch this
i don't care about this obama you know
and i but i always kept it in the back
of my mind what they were talking about
but around 2010
when i came back um i started working at
jfk airport doing the same thing i was
doing in the air force but uh for
jfk and i couldn't even afford an
apartment right i
i was making like 28 29 an hour really
good money but the tax was just
ridiculous
and uh i ended up living with this guy
named nick in um
ozone park and it's a whole other story
but this guy here man
that was the first time i ever
encountered a socialist and and knew
what a socialist was like in his house
he had like this massive communist flag
hanging on the wall
all kinds of like literature from lenin
and all kinds of stuff and
i was intrigued i'm not gonna lie
because i've never seen any of this kind
of stuff i'm like whoa look at all this
russian stuff you know what i mean so
we're sitting down we're talking about
this stuff it's like oh man you should
you should totally be a socialist like
you know or for free college or for free
healthcare you believe in equality right
i'm like yeah yeah i believe in equality
and
he's like you know what you should come
with me to this uh this rally right
and it wasn't a church in brooklyn
massive massive church there's probably
about like 200 people inside this church
and there's this guy he's up there and
he's just like
you know we're gonna we're gonna fight
for the rights and you know we're gonna
get free college because college is too
expensive rent is expensive and i'm like
yeah yeah these are all
good ideas but i remember asking the
people next to me i was like this is
cool but like how are you how are we
going to implement this
what do you mean how are we going to
implement this man we're going to tax
the rich
and i'm like tax them what like how much
like i got
where right how long he's like they're
the one percent they have the money to
pay for this and i'm like
you do realize these people have like
massive jets right like these guys have
bank accounts they can wire their money
and
disappear like there's there's no way
you're gonna write unless you're gonna
write a law
to mandate them from not leaving the
country or moving their business and i
highly doubt you're gonna be able to do
that
but no one had a real answer and it was
at that point when i came back from that
rally that i went home and i was like
let me look at ron paul
yeah and see what ron paul's talking
about and like listen you know
for the people who don't know about ron
paul or haven't haven't uh
actually heard from the guy you see him
talking he's a very you know small guy
very kind of kind of boring which is why
i believe he didn't win and he should
have won
honestly he would i think he would have
been the greatest president ever he
would have done nothing he would have he
would have pulled powers back
doctor no exactly you know he was like
i'm not listening to that i'm not doing
that we gotta we gotta bring in the
federal reserve he's talking about the
gold standard and i'm like a war
yeah and i'm like and then i thought
about i'm like listen at this point i
already figured out the whole opec
system and the petrol dollar and
why we're going to war to get the oil to
keep us going and all this stuff and i'm
like
oh man this guy definitely knows what
he's talking about i was like bringing
the gold back if you really think about
it every single
conflict we've got going on in the
united states stems from this fraction
reserve banking system
the only reason why we're doing corrupt
stuff is to pay all these taxes and pay
off this fed on the debt that will never
pay off
you know and um it really really
changed my perspective on a lot on a lot
of things but obviously i lost a lot of
friends a lot of friends and i was a
very very popular guy
growing up you know a lot of my opinions
towards obama i would
be very outspoken about this guy this
guy's not for us he's not for america
and um yeah i just uh i just kind of sat
in the sidelines for a while did you
vote for trump the first time 3 million
and 22
i voted for donald trump oh yeah but you
know something funny though that i will
tell and this surprises a lot of people
my entire life growing up i hated donald
trump really
i hated the guy because i mean
patterson's is that new york metro
basically
essentially uh essentially i mean
patterson's about 35 minutes out from
from new york city
but i hated trump my father when he came
to this country man like my father was
so gung-ho american like
i understand my language i just can't
speak it right he he was so adamant like
no you speak american you're american
we came here to be americans that's that
right my father loved donald trump
he thought he was like you know to be an
american and like you know build the
tower and do this my father would start
all these businesses and do these things
to try and uh
and you know benefit his life or
whatever right and i was like how do you
like this guy like he's a he's
he's just he's just pompous he's got his
ego through the roof he's like
you know he's dating this girl that he's
dating another woman you know what i
mean
all these kids and he's like nah that's
the american dream that guy you know
and i'm like no it wasn't until um
late 2015 a little bit before he
announced that he was running for
president that they were doing this town
hall thing and i can't find the video
anymore for life
if you can that'll be fantastic but i
believe it was msnbc it was like a
little town hall
thing and they were asking him questions
about um just his
his stance on a lot of different things
and they asked them about the war
in iraq and he was like you know the war
in iraq was a mistake we should never
went into war with iraq
um if anybody really did their research
they'd find out it was the saudis
okay it was the saudis said a straight
line like that i was like oh my god he's
talking about saudi arabia like
i never other than ron paul i never saw
another politician straight up call out
saudi arabia for doing 911 because those
hijackers were saudi arabian they
weren't iraqi they weren't
a good right and i guess there was uh
some some news i don't know
you have to factor this one where they
uh they allowed the families to sue
saudi arabia or there was something
going on
i heard about that i'm not too clear on
that as well too but
the point that i'm making is like we
know that about at least 11 of those
hijackers were saudi arabian so i was
like okay that's
that's interesting he's actually
bringing that up and then i asked him
you know what's one of the biggest
economic problems that are facing the
united states and he said
it's the fraction reserve banking system
it's the it's the federal said that yes
you cannot find this clip anymore you
said this i was sitting down i was
watching with my boy gord we're watching
in the room and i'm like yo this guy is
talking about the federal reserve
the only other person i heard talking
about this was ron paul said i said okay
there may be something to this trump guy
you know i know he's been talking about
china forever
and trade and and bringing everything
back so so
this is an intro yeah yeah that was good
that was awesome story i mean
dude you you you defied orders you
thought were
illegal or or what it's not
even a matter of them being legal or
illegal because if the president says
that it's legal even if it's wrong
slavery was legal
exactly right it was more of a moral
thing you know um
i didn't feel that it it made sense for
us to go out and and do these
these atrocities on top of that what
made me
more upset than the fact that we were
doing this was the fact that
on cnn and afn they're saying that oh
the humanitarian no-fly zone was a
success and you look at all the other
news coverage in england
you get access to all kinds of news fake
news they're talking about the complete
opposite
the complete opposite of what's really
going on and i said they're definitely
lying to me
and i i always kind of held this facade
that it's like you know we're fighting
for freedom we're doing the right thing
and
i was like this is this ain't it so now
you
are running in a d plus 16 that's like
very democrat district
it's uh it's the ninth district in north
jersey
patterson that city that is that's
that's where the voter fraud is
that's the big story that's that's you
that's where you're at yeah
so anyway there's your intro uh if you
guys haven't already
smash the like button we're going to be
talking about a lot of this i do want to
i do want to jump over and talk about
what's going on the national guard and
kenosha now to get everybody here okay
cool and your opinions on all this stuff
with the riots and everything like that
so for everybody that's just tuning in
you can uh subscribe we do the show
monday through friday live hit the like
button like i just said
and uh got a bunch of stories but that's
billy prempe i am the guy
yeah yeah yeah man i got i gotta say
like normally we just do a couple
minutes for the intro but your story
telling talking about the war
libya that's that's rad bro i'm i'm
impressed that you were
you are willing to say no to something
you thought was wrong believe me i got
in a lot of trouble for it
yeah and that's that's that's honorable
bro because i see these cops
you know they the the governor say i'm
going to issue an edict
in violation of the constitution and so
many of these cops are just like okay
let's go and do it yep no you i i like
that i like the guys
the sheriffs and everything in virginia
who are like we're not going to enforce
these laws
i like the cops to say if the
constitution says no you don't do it
right thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you